nous sommes très heureux d'accueillir
Monsieur Louis Galois qui a été
président du groupe public ferroviaire
pendant 10 ans de
1996 à 2006 un président emblématique
aimé des chemineau il faut le dire et
qui au moment de son départ en 2006
pouvait afficher des résultats de
redressement de l'entreprise qui étaient
significatifs notamment au regard des
fréquentations voyageur avec c'est ce
que disait souvent la presse au moment
où vous avez quitté vos fonctions
monsieur le président malgré tout
l'oursin du fra de ferroviaire qui
restait euh bien présent dans la
chaussure qui ensuite devait être euh
endossé par euh euh madame
Idrac un un Président je disais aussi
qui a je vais le dire plutôt euh qui a
connu sur ce sujet du fra ferroviaire le
prer paquet puis le 2ème paquet euh
ferroviaire européen avec euh aussi euh
cette réalité de l'ouverture à la
concurrence qui est devenue effective au
au moment où vous étiez président du
groupe public
ferroviaire et avec je crois sur le
sujet du fret là aussi beaucoup
d'articles de presse qui parlent de
votre expérience à la tête de la SNCF le
raconte une surprise qui était la vôtre
au début sur la vêuseté de certaines
infrastructures je crois que c'était au
Bourget que vous avez eu cette première
ce premier contact avec une réalité du
fra ferroviaire qui au regarde des
expériences aéronautiques que vous aviez
eu auparavant était celle d'un
sous-investissement chronique bref
monsieur le Président votre témoignage
sur ce processus d'ouverture à la
concurrence qui est l'un des cœur de
cette commission d'enquête sera précieux
alors que pendant la la période où vous
avez exercé cette présidence comme
auparavant le pourcentage de la part
modale continuait à baisser sur
l'ensemble des tonnages
marchandises qui qui étit transporté en
France et du reste cette baisse de la
part modale je fais é qu ce qu'on a
parfois dit était une réalité européenne
puisque quand on regarde les chiffres je
crois je cite de tête entre
1970 et
1997 le le pourcentage de parmodal
transporté par le le train est passé de
21 à 8,5 % en Europe donc c'était une
une réalité de décélération qui était
d'ailleurs plus prononcée dans certains
pays que que qu'en France à l'époque
Monsieur le Président donc nos questions
vont être multiples j'en ouvre
quelques-unes pour nourrir d'emblé votre
propos préliminaire
euh des questions sur la place du fret
pendant 10 ans vous 10 ans de présidence
dans la stratégie globale de fret SNCF
des questions sur les effets de la
séparation entre SNCF et
RFF en
1997 sur le le frait de ferroviaire des
difficultés qui ont pu exister avec le
gestionnaire
d'infrastructure euh nous serions
également heureux monsieur le Président
au vu de votre expérience euh et de
votre autorité de recueillir votre
analyse du contexte actuel sur le choix
de discontinuité qu'a effectué le
gouvernement pour répondre à une
procédure ouverte par d'enquête
approfondie ouverte par la Commission
européenne en janvier 2023 à l'encontre
de frit SNCF plus globalement quelles
sont vos préconisations quant au rôle du
fret ferroviaire dans la stratégie de
réindustrialisation de notre pays euh
quelles sont vos préconisations dans un
contexte qui a beaucoup changer euh par
rapport à 2006 au regard de la manière
dont les entreprises se posent la
question du transport de leur
marchandises dans le monde contemporain
quelle place voyez-vous pour l'opérateur
historique sur le marché du fret dans un
segment du fret qui lui est beaucoup
plus large et comment voyez-vous
l'organisation de la concurrence de
façon effective et l'articulation entre
cette concurrence et un soutien
nécessaire dans un secteur qui notamment
pour le vagon isolé et structurellement
déséquilibré monsieur le Président je le
rappelle cette audition comme toute
celle que nous menons est retransmise en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale sera aussi disponible en vidéo
pour tous ceux qui en feront la demande
je vous laisserai la parole pour une
intervention liminire d'une dizaine ou
d'une quinzaine de minutes puis nous
poursuivrons nos échanges avec des
questions que je poserai d'abord puis
monsieur le rapporteur et ensuite les
collègues députés qui sont présents
auparavant monsieur président et je sais
que vous avez une une une expérience
solide des commissions d'enquête donc
vous ne serez pas surpris de ce rappel
formel l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires précise
que les personnes auditionnées par
celle-ci dans le cadre d'une commission
d'enquête doivent prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc monsieur le
Président à bien vouloir lever la main
droite et à dire je le jure je j nous
vous écoutons attentivement pour une
bonne dizaine de minutes Mons monsieur
le
Président lequel il faut appuyer ou
merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je voudrais d'abord je suis
très sensible à votre invitation
d'autant plus que j'ai quitté
l'entreprise il y a 16 ans comme vous
l'avez rappelé que de qu'après cela j'ai
fait des avions et des automobiles et
que donc je n'ai pas
suivi la destinée du frê
ferroviaire autrement que par les
journaux et je n'ai pas d'autres
informations euh sur euh ce ce qui lui
est arrivé et sur
le l'issue que vous évoquez euh de la
discontinuité alors vous m'interrogez
sur la place du FR de ferroviaire de 96
à 2006 euh euh je je je crois que ce
n'est que vous l'avez dit ce n'est pas
un mystère que ça a été euh euh un
oursin ou un caillou dans la chaussure
c'est-à-dire que la situation du
fret n'était pas catastrophique mais
elle n'ar n'arrivion pas à redresser le
fret et je pense que il y avait
certainement des responsabilités du côté
de la SNCF que je ne veux pas nier des
responsabilités
d'organisation notamment l'organisation
du travail qui ne facilitait pas la
souplesse que requiert le frais de
ferrovière mais je je je pense que
l'essentiel n'est pas là l'essentiel
vous l'avez évoqué c'est d'abord le fait
que les infrastructures
ferroviaires du fret n'ont pas été
modernisé qu'elles
étaient probablement pour une part
obsolète et que en en dehors de certains
chantiers de transport
combinés très peu d'investissement on
été fait dans ce domaine et Réseau Ferré
de France qui avait tendance naturel que
je ne critique
pas à donner la priorité aux
investissements qui pouvaent lui
rapporter en terme de péage le fr lu
rapportait très peu en terme de péage ne
pouvait aller que vers les
voyageurs d'autant plus que il y a du
côté de l'infrastructure une question
toujours sous-jacente sur la sécurité
des circulations et il est clair que
pour RFF la priorité et je encore une
fois je je le trouve probablement adopt
le
même le même comportement la priorité é
d'assurer la la sécurité des des des
transports voyageurs donc nous nous
trouvions avec une infrastructure frite
extrêmement assez véuste
et avec une seule ligne frite dédiée
nous l'évoquion dans l'antichambre qui
est lyonmseille par la rive droite du rô
qui d'ailleurs est un peu moins dédié
actuellement puisque le TER
l'empreinte dans des proportions
relativement limitées pour le moment
mais qui peuvent avoir tendance étantner
la densification des trafics TER à aller
au-delà ça c'est le premier élément le
second élément c'est évidemment la
question de la
concurrence je n'hésite pas à dire que
la concurrence du camion vis-à-vis du
fra de ferroviaire est totalement
inégale les camions circule sur une
grande sur le réseau routier sans péage
autre que les péages d'autoroute mais je
rappelle que près de la moitié des
autoroutes existantes en France n'ont
pas de péage vous avez toute la Bretagne
vous avez la vallée d'Alsace vous avez
une partie de de de Paris-Toulouse vous
avez vous avez Bordeaux Bordeaux
enail vous avez une partie de ce que
j'appelle autoroute sens large route à
quatre voix euh qui est emprunté par des
trafics internationaux sans payer de
péage et et et c'est un avantage
évidemment considérable et j'ai pu
mesurer la difficulté d'appliquer un
péage au transport routiers Madame
Royale s'y est collé ça échoué il y a
également évidemment les avantages
fiscaux liés au la détaxation du
carburant encore une fois le
gouvernement a pointé c'est à peine le
nez
que les responsables du transport
routier ont dit c'est pas le moment nous
som en difficulté c'est pas le
moment ça c'est l'actualité la plus
récente donc il y a un
problème le transport routier est un
transport beaucoup
plus
souple qui fait du point à
point qui a donc des avantages par
rapport au transport ferroviaire en
terme de commodité
et le transport ferroviaire a des
rigidités inhérentes à son mode de
fonctionnement qui qui font que si le
transport routier en plus a des
avantages économiques la concurrence est
extrêmement rude je voudrais évoquer un
troisième
élément c'est que la
désindustrialisation de la France a fait
qu'une partie des gros
trafics a disparu et que le les les
points de de de massification du trafic
qui sont en Allemagne les grands
ports la région de
[Musique]
dusbourg n'existe plus en France parce
que les ports français n'ont pas du tout
la taille des ports allemands et d'autre
part par ou Rotterdam qui est quasiment
un P
allemand enfin je voudrais pas vexer les
les Hollandais mais il est bien
Rotterdam est bien bien au pays B mais
c'est quand même un port qui qui qui qui
vit du trafic de de l'Allemagne donc on
ces grands ports
sont au service de la massification des
trafic et et et l'industrie lourde
parallèlement a disparu donc une des
bases les plus solides du trafic de fret
a disparu moi je me souviens quand je
suis arrivé à la 7F il y avait encore
les trains de minerais entre la Lorine
et les et et d'un kerque il y avait
encore on transporté des brames de dans
les deux sens euh
donc il y avait un trafic qui
actuellement cette massification
n'existe plus le Tiss industriel
français n'apporte plus cette
massification voilà ce que je peux dire
sur les raisons qui j'ai dépassé le
cadre de de mes 10 années
et encore une fois je veux pas exclure
que nous'yons pas été très bon mais tout
cela fait un contexte qui est évidemment
extrêmement extrêmement
lourd le le
fret a beaucoup d'avantages mais il a
les inconvénients de sa
rigidité voilà ce que je peux dire à ce
stade alors la concurrence vous
m'interrogez sur la concurrence
la concurrence elle
elle est bénéfique sur un marché en
expansion
ou lorsquelle est capable de créer
l'expansion du
trafic mais lorsqu'on est sur un trafic
stagnant ou en décroissance elle peut
avoir des effets
pervers et je je pense que la situation
moi j'étais pas contre le fait qu'on met
en concurrence j'attendais de voir les
résultats est-ce que la part modale du
ferroviaire a augmenté sur les 10
dernières années parce que au fond la
concurrence réelle ces 10 12 dernières
années est-ce que cette par modale a
augmenté j'ai pas les chiffres mais je
n'ai pas l'impression que ça soit
significatif mais je je réserve ma
réponse sur ce point parce que je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas les
chiffres voilà ce que je peux vous dire
sur sur le contexte actuel les décisions
qui sont prises moi je ne suis pas
capable je ne connais pas le
dossier j'ai compris qu'il y avait une
dette de l'ordre de 5 milliards pour le
frê je je je je je lis ce que j'ai eu
dans les journaux et que pour ne pas
rembourser cette dette à la SNCF puisque
cette dette serait remboursée à la SNCF
par frit SNCF rembourserait ça
SNCF pour éviter cela qui mettrait
évidemment en faillite l'activité frite
telle qu'elle
est on a on préconise la
discontinuité pourquoi pas mais c
discontinuité ça c'est ça saccompagne de
de perte de trafic
significative 30 % du trafic 20 % du
chiffre
d'affaires et je n'ai pas compris
que sur les 30 % du trafic que la SNF
était obligé de rétrocéder pour au moins
ans je n'ai pas compris que ce soit les
trafics les plus déficitaires
c'est-à-dire que ce sont les trafics une
partie des trafics qui rapportent de
l'argent à Fred
SNF qui sont euh transféré à la
concurrence je ne pense pas que ça va
faciliter la tâche de ceux qui ont
redresser Fred SNCF j'avais compris
d'ailleurs sur les deux dernières années
Fred SNCF était à l'équilibre c'est ce
que disent les journaux hein je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas d'information spécifique
donc je je trouve que
cette
sanction si encore ça rapportait du
trafic pour le fret mais ça va pas faire
un camion de moins sur les
routes euh je donc j'ai une petite
incompréhension je m'exprime euh avec
modération parce que je ne connais pas
le dossier je vous dis ce que j'en par
que mon expérience ancienne et longue
puisque je suis vieux me conduit à
penser sur je essaie de répondre à vos
questions sur les préconisations pour le
fr ferroviaire je voudrais là vous venez
d'auditionner Jean-Pierre farandou vous
pouvez considérer que je dis exactement
la même chose que lui je ne veux pas me
distinguer de mon de mon successeur avec
lequel j'ai les meilleures relations
pour faire des prcon sur un sujet que je
connais très
mal en tout cas il y a un problème de
concurrence rail route qui doit être
abordé ça me paraî
clair je
pas tant que tant que ce problème ne
sera pas résolu nous aurons évidemment
des difficultés a certain des
investissements d'inrastructure à faire
mais je suis incapable de vous dire où
et comme vous l'avez suggéré dans votre
propos liminaire il est probable que si
on veut maintenir un trafic de vagon
isolés ou de train entier irrégulier et
cetera il va bien falloir que quelqu'un
accompagne et soutienne la SNCF sinon sa
logique propre la conduira à arrêter ces
trafic
et voilà voilà ce que je peux vous dire
en terme
de d'introduction je vous ai à peu près
dit tout ce que je savais merci merci
monsieur le Président je vais vous poser
trois questions et puis peut-être faire
un petit rappel au passé pour que vous
nous éclairiez sur des discussions que
vous aviez déjà au moment où vous étiez
président de la SNCF avec le
Gouvernement sur ce sujet avec la
Commission
européenne première
question pendant les 10 ans où vous avez
exercé la présidence du groupe public
ferroviaire avez-vous eu le senti
que ce sujet du fra de ferroviaire
faisait l'objet d'une politique publique
suffisante à la fois en terme de de
priorité et de soutien financier je dis
cela parce que l'une des choses qu'a dit
votre prédécesseur c'est que le niveau
d'ê publique aujourd'hui à loué au
secteur du fret ferroviaire est plus
beaucoup plus important qu'il ne l'était
par le passé avez-vous sentiment d'une
politique publique suffisante et
cohérente je le dis d' plus volontiers
que vous avez présidé la NCF avec des
gouvernements de sensibilité politique
différentes en face de vous euh deuxème
question vous êtes vous avez construit
un projet industriel pour laasncf et le
ferroviaire c'est une industrie en soi
quel part cette dans ce projet
industriel tenait le fret de façon
spécifique sachant que l'une des
particularités de ce projet c'était la
gestion par activité
euh trème question c'est le cœur de ce
que vous nous disiez sur le la
concurrence et c'est la première
concurrence pour le rail au-delà de
au-delà du sujet fretcnf il y a le sujet
rail contre route c'est la première des
concurrences effectivement il y a
beaucoup d'interlocuteurs sont
intervenus ici en nous disant que en
fait la concurrence existait avant 2003
200005 pour le pour frsncf mais c'était
la concurrence de la route la seule
différence c'est que il y avait eu des
concurrents sur le même mode de
transport comment selon vous
rééquilibrer ça c'est plus au citoyens
que je m'adresse cette concurrence entre
aux citoyens très éclairés entre le rail
et et la route et puis je parlais tout à
l'heure d'un d'un rappel au
passé je je c'est normal en préparant
ces audition se replonge dans la presse
il a quelques années et et il se trouve
que on a retrouvé plusieurs articles qui
est à l'automne 2003 au moment où il y
avait la question du la du plan Veyron
de redressement du fra de ferroviaire
euh qui mentionne d'une part ce ce
déficit qui était je je le rappelle au
1er semestre 2003 on est donc avant
l'ouverture effective à la concurrence
de
267,8 million d'euros rien que pour le
premer semestre pour frit SNCF et des
objectifs que vous donniez à ce plan
Verron de retour à l'équilibre en 2006
et à l'époque euh vous euh vous
souhaitiez qu'il y ait une solution
publique au désendettement de frais t
SNCF je cite le désendettement fait
partie intégrale du plan de sauvetage de
Louis Gallois estime à proche du dossier
ces dernières semaines Marc Verron le
nouveau patron de la branche a fait le
siège du budget du Trésor et des
transports mais Bery rechigne d'autant
plus que l'État n'a guerre de réserve et
se trouve déjà dans le collimateur de
Bruxelles je cite une solution imaginée
par SNCF consisterait à faire porter la
dette du fret par le service annexe
d'amortissement de la dette le SAD
rattaché à la société mais doté d'une
comptabilité distincte la mais la
contribution de l'État au sad relevant
d'une subvention publique au sens du
traité de Maastricht cette cette option
risque une fois de plus d'attirer les
foudres de la Commission européenne ce
qui prouve que ce sujet de l'aide
publique à la compensation du du des
déficits à l'époque chronique de de
fredncf était déjà posé sur la table à
ce moment-là donc quelle mémoire G
z-vous de ces discussions que vous aviez
avec eux alors c'est loin on est bien
d'accord c'est il y a 20 ans et et vous
avez fait 1000 choses depuis et on le
sait
et c'est une raison d'ailleurs du regard
très respectueux que nous jetons les uns
et les autres sur votre expérience et et
votre
témoignage mais quel souvenir
gardez-vous de ces discussions avec la
Commission et avec le gouvernement je
vous remercie monsieur le Président sur
le premier sujet est-ce que le fr
ferroviaire a bénéficié du soutien du
gouvernement
oui dans les paroles je n'ai jamais eu
de parolle qui pouvaient remettre en
cause le soutien que le gouvernement
apporté à cette
activité je me souviens même des lettres
de mission que j'adressais à Monsieur
maire qui était ministre des Finances
enfin des projets de la déission il m'
renvoyé corrigé et en en en l'IDE de
mission et dans lequel le redressement
du fret était avait sa part
euh ça ne s'est pas traduit par des
espèces sonnantes et tribuchantes de
manière
significative c'était d'ailleurs pas
très facile parce que commenciion est
dans le collimateur de Bruxelles sur les
a on avait pas besoin d'être en
concurrence pour être dans le
collimateur sur les a parce que la
concurrence avec la route la la FNTR et
autres étaient les premiers à regarder
ce qui se passait du côté de des aides
de afred SNF
euh donc euh j'ai pas eu le sentiment
que nous ayons eu un soutien financier
important même si euh euh nous avions je
n'ai jamais été dans les actions
que nous pouvions mener pour essayer de
redresser le fret par une intervention
publique hein je le dis tout de
suite alors sur le plan
veryron ce n'est pas nous qui discutions
avec la Commission de Bruxelles c'est
l'État qui discute avec la Commission de
Bruxelles donc moi je n'ai pas eu de
contact
formel à Bruxelles sur ce sujet et je
pense d'ailleurs que c'était aussi Simp
qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul
interlocuteur ce que nous demandions
effectivement c'était d'alléger le poids
de la dette parce qu'on nous avait
allégé un premier nous av eu un premier
allègement de dette en 1901 1997 oui
euh il y en a eu depuis un autre
beaucoup plus important par la
suite quoi quelques astuces que l'on
puisse présenter on peut faire le tour
tout ce que l'on veut on est toujours
requalifié requalifiable à Bruxelles en
tte d'État hein donc je j'avais oublié
vous me le rappelez mais maintenant ça
me revient en mémoire que nous avions
proposer de passer par le service
d'amortissement de la dette mais
c'était enfin je voudrais pas être
sévère avec moi-même mais c'était quand
même osé ça n'avait pas pas beaucoup de
chance de
passer donc voilà
donc et et et vous avait raison
d'évoquer le fait que le fret en 2003
allait mal allait mal c'est un petit peu
redressé par la suite mais pas de
manière très
significative sur
euh la part la part du fret dans le
projet industriel j'en'i pas une mémoire
très précise mais il y avait un volet
fret c'est évident il avait un volet
fret et
euh tel que la SNCF fonctionne il aurait
été impossible qu'il n'y ait pas un
volet fret que ce volet frite était euh
conçu dans la perspective et et nous
avions déjà en tête même si nous ne le
disions pas que il faudrait que le Fred
soit se prépare à une concurrence
intramodale la concurrence intermodale
était évidemment le sujet majeur et ça
continue à l'être à mon
avis la concurrence intramodale est
beaucoup
moins déséquilibrée que la concurrence
intermodale et la gestion par activité
j'allais dire c'était une
une orientation de bon sens chaque
activité doit se gérer ça n'empêche pas
des péréquations entre activités on le
sait euh le TGV a payé euh euh notamment
euh les train Intercités hein
et et et et je je je je ne voudrais pas
que ce soit mal interprété mais
peut-être un tout petit peu le frite
aussi même si nous étions encore une
fois sous le contrôle de la Commission
de Bruxelles en tout cas euh
sur les trins Intercités je je suis
formel le TGV a soutenu l'activité le
TER éant équilibré lui-même
par les conventions avec les
régions comment rééquilibrer le trafic r
route c'est la question que à laquelle
je je n'ai pas de réponse si ce n'est
que comment on peut pas transformer
complètement le mode de
transport ferroviaire il faut s'attaquer
au trafic routier mais je croyais que
c'était un objectif
de qui dépassait largement la
concurrence frite ferroviaire route qui
touchait à la transition
énergétique est-ce que l'on veut
continuer à développer un trafic routier
qui est quand même un trafic
essentiellement constitué de camions
roulant au diesel au
gazol je pense que là il y a une
question il y aura peut-être le passage
des camions àélectrique
l'exclu pas du tout il est même possible
que la solution hydrogène pour lequel
j'ai des doutes pour l'automobile puisse
être adapté pour le les camions
mais pour le
moment c'est un trafic qui n'est
absolument pas pénétré par l'électricité
ou l'hydrogène est
entièrement il est
entièrement avec des énergie fossile et
donc il faut il faut en tenir compte et
puis moi je me pose la question de de la
gratuité de la circulation sur une
partie du
réseau je pense que là il y a il y a
quelque chose à
regarder l'cotax avait un
sens entraîné les bonniss rouges et
autre
gracieuseté donc je je ne méconnais pas
la difficulté de faire passer ça et
d'ailleurs on a vu dès que le
gouvernement a évoqué l'idée qui n'est
pas l'écotaxe mais de remettre en cause
le privilège fiscal sur
l'essence sur le Gazo à quelle vitesse
la réaction a été vive du côté du
transport
routier mais il faudra passer par
là merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président on pourrait je pas que les
collègues évoqueront beaucoup de sujets
puisque l'une des autres évolutions
majeures que vous avez vécu comme
président du Group public ferroviaire
c'était la régionalisation du transport
de voyageurs qui est par fois mise en
cause sur la perturbation qu'elle a
apporté dans certaines circulation fride
par la la saturation des des sons je je
peux dire un mot là-dessus c'est un des
bienfaits on transporte des gens on fait
pas circuler les trains pour rien et
effectivement le cadencement comme on
commençait à l'évoquer à mon époque et
cetera ça va dans le sens de ce que dà
moi j'habite en banlieu je prends le
train très régulièrement je suis heureux
de savoir que j'ai le train
6h un train tous les quarts d'heur qu'à
danser donc je je veux pas le plaindre
mais quand vous voulez faire venir un
train de fret depuis Le Havre sur Paris
il y a pas la place vous pouvez pas le
faire passer vous avez quelques trains
grand ligne et puis vous avez une
ftitude de
de de Transiliens
et je pense que c'est on peut pas peut
pas le regretter le problème c'est c'est
c'est l'infrastructure qui est pas
disponible et et et Le Havre ne
deviendra un lieu de massification de
trafic comme il devrait l'être que le
jour où on sera capable de de de
résoudre ce problème de l'accès à
l'ouest de
Paris on a d'ailleurs prévu
d'auditionner le le directeur général
délégué d'aropa qui qui s'occupe du port
du Havre monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez la
parole merci
monsieur
voilà merci Monsieur le le
Président il y a
une
dans depuis le début de ces
auditions il y a une part
d'interrogation qui persiste sur cette
séquence au tournant du des années 2000
c'est
le le rapport à la Commission
européenne les
ministres que nous avons auditionné
restent peu
diser sur et bien
les le travail nécessairement engagé
notamment entre 2003 et 2005 avec la
Commission européenne euh travail où où
s'épulle en fait
deux deux décisions majeurs la première
restructuration lourde de fret CNCF avec
le plan veryron et bien
évidemment la l'accord de la Commission
européenne sur l'aide d'un milliard
5 vousmême indiquez que vous n'avez pas
eu de contact formel
avec avec
Bruxelles ni informel
donc nous nous interrogeons sur tout du
moins pour ce qui me concerne
sur
l'articulation qui reste majeure
entre ce premier plan Verron qui est un
plan dit à l'époque je crois de la
dernière chance et qui était un un plan
euh très significatif pour le frit en
matière dirais-je d'attrition de moyens
matériels
locomotive et cetera en
matière de trafic
lui-même en matière
de d'agent puisque à partir de 2003 je
crois qu'il y a trois plans de
licenciement qui sont
gage euh tout du moins un plan
de de réduction d'emploi voilà
euh et en même temps euh nous
retrouvons quasiment ce plan Verron en
écho dans l'accord avec la Commission
européenne de
20042005 auquel s'ajoute l'ouverture à
la
concurrence donc euh euh nous
sommes peut-être fondés d'interroger
sur et bien qui qui était à la manœuvre
je dirais euh à cette à cette date euh
entre finalement des politiques qui nous
disent et bien la libéralisation je cite
cétait pas le
sujet l'ouverture à la concurrence
c'était pas le sujet et
et bien vous-même en toute en toute
honnêteté qui qui qui qui indiquit et
bien
Bruxelles connaît pas en quelque sorte
euh comment avveit-vous un élément de
réponse sur cette dichotomie
entre entre un moment
majeur de
l'évolution du frit de freet SNCF et euh
euh cette absence j' dirais de euh
d'élément de réponse
euh dans
la dans la relation à la à la Commission
européenne pour lesquelle vous dites
tout de même et ça c'est c'est c'est
fort intéressant euh que et
bien vous étiez déjà dans le collimateur
de de Bruxelles sur les les aides
publiques et là à l'initiative du
secteur routier la
FNTR vous citez
la je n'ai pas de démonstration formelle
de cela je dirais que le secteur routier
n'avait pas de raison de rester inerte
vis-à-vis d'un plan Fred dont vous me
rappelez ce que j'avais oublié qu'il
était assorti d'un mliard 500 millions
de subvention ce que que je ce que ce
que de soutien ce que j'avais oublié
quand j'ai dit qu'il n'y avait pas eu
d'effort de l'État 15illard 500 millions
c'est un effort
significatif non non mais je voilà
diichotomie interrogation
ou oui allez-y monsieur le Président et
et je il ne sera pas dit que j'aurais
coupé le micro à monsieur le rapporteur
cette dichotomie et
est ne me choque
pas c'est l'État qui négocié à Bruxelles
c'est lui qui a négocié me semble-t-il
pour l'accord sur la discontinuité ce
n'est pas la SNCF qui est allé à
Bruxelles négocier son
plan ensuite alors évidemment il ne va
pas l'état ne va pas sans débat et
consultation et échange avec la
SNCF et nous nons jamais présenté le
plan veryron si nous avavions pas eu
l'aval non seulement du conseil
d'administration de la SNCF je me
souviens plus dans quelle circonstances
je l'ai présenté mais je suis sûr de
l'avoir présenté
et et et du gouvernement donc ce plan
bénéficiait du soutien du
gouvernement et euh le gouvernement est
allé le défendre à Bruxelles moi ça ne
me choque pas c'est ce c'est c'est comme
ça que ça se passe et pas uniquement
pour la France
euh
je on pourrait imaginer que l'entreprise
soit euh associé à ces consultations
c'est un autre schéma ce n'est pas celui
qui a été retenu donc euh et on n' pas
fait pour cette affaire un cas
particulier de la SNCF c'est l'État qui
négocie les dossiers d'aide
d'État alors donc j'ai j'ai vu une
question de Monsieur Thomas porte
monsieur le député de C saint vous avez
la
parole pardon
excusez-moi merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Président plusieurs plusieurs
question d'abord vous avez évoqué au
départ
votre regard un peu étonnner sur cette
procédure de discontinuité notamment le
fait qu'on oblige Fred SNCF à céder 23
flux euh parmi les plus rentables euh de
son activité est-ce que vous pouvez
confirmer ce que vous avez dit
c'est-à-dire une inquiétude sur le fait
que cette procédure de discontinuité
pourrait se traduire dans les prochains
mois par un transfert de camion euh sur
la route et non pas sur le rail puisque
c'est quand même un des objectifs qui
aujourd'hui nous anime c'est évidemment
d'avoir un grand service public
ferroviaire de marchandis et voyageurs
mais d'éviter qu'il y ait un report
modal inversé qui se traduise par des
camions sur la route euh deème question
au cœur du débat il est reproché au
groupe SNCF d'avoir épongé les dettes de
la filiale de frit
etncf est-ce que c'est une pratique qui
est aussi courante dans les autres pays
européens ou est-ce que c'est une
spécificité
française deuxème question on parle
beaucoup d'aide publique sur le réseau
du fret en France est-ce que vous avez
connaissance de par votre passage à la
tête de la SNCF est-ce qu'il y a eu des
aides publiques dans d'autres pays avant
que la France n frit SNCF et enfin
dernière question est-ce qu'on n pas
aussi arrivé à un moment où finalement
on p la stratégie ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure du tout TGV au détriment du fret
parce que moi je suis toujours un peu
surpris parce qu'on parle de
l'infrastructure qui ne qui est en
mauvais état qui a un besoin d'investir
de la rénover pour relancer le fret mais
j'ai l'impression queand on interroge
tous les dirigeants de la SNCF depuis
les 20 dernières années tous livrent le
constat d'un réseau qui n'est pas à la
hauteur d'un besoin d'investissement euh
et euh le constat finalement qui a étit
le votre à l'époque on le retrouve
aujourd'hui 20 ans après moi j'ai une
question pourquoi si on sait depuis 20
ans que le réseau n'est pas à la hauteur
qu'il fallait de l'investissement massif
pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait et pourquoi
on a laissé mourir ce réseau qui
permettrait aujourd'hui d'avoir un
opérateur Fred public de haut niveau
parce que vous avez parlé notamment du
fait qu'il fallait que les marchandises
i des ports pour les mettre sur le rail
on a un problème d'intermodalité avec
les marchés d'intérêts nationaux avec
les ports on a un certain nombre
d'embranchements temporaires qui sont
inutilisable du fait de l'abandon donc
le wagon isolé n'est plus utile parce
qu'il ne dessert plus les entreprises de
proximité pourquoi pendant 20 ans si ce
constat a été fait selon vous il n'y a
pas eu d'investissement massif sur le
réseau pour permettre que il y ait une
régénération permanente et ne pas
arriver à une une situation qui est
aujourd'hui dramatique pour notre réseau
ferroviaire je je je refais une une
précision sur les investissements sur le
réseau on en a parlé beaucoup la semaine
dernière
euh le le constat qu'on a tous partagé
c'est que sur le réseau fret dédié ou
sur les infrastructures fret dédié les
gardes de triage il y avait eu cette
cette insuffisance très chronique du des
investissements sur l'ensemble du réseau
qui est circulé par euh et et du fret et
euh du voyageur sousinvestissement aussi
mais timide redressement à partir de
2003 c'est ce que ce qui est ce que
montre après le rapport de l'Institut
polytechnique de Lausanne et je je me
doute bien que vous vous en souvenez
très bien monsieur le Président euh et
et réaccélération à la faveur du plan de
relance récent ça c'est c'est ça se voit
objectivement même si euh notre réseau
aujourd'hui ne rajeunit pas mais qu'il
ne vieillit plus au rythme des
investissements des 200 milliards 8
annuels du contrat de performance
monsieur le
Président je n'ai pas dit que la
décision Bruxelles à l'estradure par un
transfert du rail vers la route j'ai dit
que ça ne ferait pas un camion de moins
sur les routes ce qui est pas pareil
c'estàd que il y a pas de raison que ça
entraîn d' un camion de moins sur les
routes je je je j'ai tenu ensuite un
raisonnement de bon sens qui est que si
on enlève des trafics rentables à une
activité qui ne l'est pas
évidemment on naméliore pas la
rentabilité globale du fret ça c'est
clair et euh il y a ça veut dire que la
fr va être dans les prochaines années
une situation relativement difficile du
fait de C trafic qui lu ont été
enlevé vous m'interrogez
sur l'attitude de la
commission la commission elle a une
pensée moins de la cohérence elle n'aime
pas les entreprises publiques de
monopole voilà
et
donc il se trouve que je m'intéresse
actuellement au dossier de EDF pour
d'autres raison et je constate
que les
mêmes
perception on les retrouve à la
Commission sur la SNCF nous sommes la
SNCF a toujours
été soupçonné
j'en un terme peut-être
excessif soupçonné d'être
euh de d'être assis sur une une sorte de
monopole qui lui permettrait d'abord de
ne pas faire d'effort de ne pas aller
chercher de nouveaux clients et que il
fallait qu'il y ait de la concurrence
pour stimuler le marché le développer
bon je demande à voir ce qui quel a été
le résultat depuis depuis 10 ou 15 ans
sur le fret en en France parce que les
difficultés que j'évoque pour le fret de
sensef sont les même pour les
concurrents pas de massification du
trafic les infrastructures pas
disponibles les autres c'est pareil
hein
donc on a une difficulté de débat avec
avec Bruxell plus global hein je je je
je parle comme citoyen là pas comme
ancien président de la on a une
difficulté plus globale euh à discuter
avec Bruxelles sur
euh sur les entreprises qui étaient en
position de
monopole ce monopole avait certainement
des inconvénients moi je ne suis pas
encore une fois je suis pas opposé à
l'ouverture de la concurrence du fret
mais je veux en voir les résultats dans
la croissance du
trafic je pourrais dire pour
l'électricité que je voudrais bien voir
les résultats dans le prix de
l'électricité
ou bon donc je je je donc euh bon voilà
alors est-ce que
[Musique]
c'est les Allemands qui ont une un
opérateur très puissant qui est la
dejban
ont su peut-être mieux gesticuler à
Bruxelles que nous sur pour présenter
les choses de manière plus acceptable
ils ont ils sont ouverts à la
concurrence plus tôt ils ont
volontairement laissé filer des traficsf
ils ont laissé filer des trafic
volontairement peut-être un terme
excessif mais ils ont laissé filer des
trafic donc ils ont été un peu moins
dans le collimateur j'ai compris qu'ils
y revenaient mais
bon on verra quant aux autres pays il y
a très peu de frit dans les autres pays
pays où il y a du fret c'est la France
c'était la France l'Allemagne Bel
Belgique
Pays-Bas l'Espagne il y en a très peu
très très peu trafic camion
essentiellement l'Italie également très
peu de de de de trafic frit donc c'est
pas des pays qui sur lequel qui soit
significatif pour ce
nous y a-t-il eu des a publiqu en
Allemagne je n'en suis pas je n'en ai
pas la confirmation par que je sais
c'est que l'Allemagne a des points de
massification de trafic extrêmement
significatif que ça soit l'usine de
Volkswagen à volksburg que ce soit
dusburg et toute la sidérurgie allemande
qui est regroupée et que ce soit le port
de Hambourg ou de Brem
ou comme je le disais le port de
Rotterdam donc ils sont des lieux de
massification de trafic que nous n'avons
pas les ports français sont des petits
ports comp entre guillemets comparé au
port du Nord pour multiples raisons sur
lesquelles je n'ai pas je nai pas
d'expertise
mais ces lieux de mafication ont aidé la
DEB à faire face puis peut-être qu'ils
sont mieux débrouillés que nous aussi
moi je ne veux pas du tout dire qu'on
s'est très bien débrouillé quand le
résultat est pas bon il faut quand même
accepter de prendre une partie de la
responsabilité sur son dos peut-être que
nous avons été trop lo à réagir et
peut-être que N nons pas montré la
capacité à à nous adapter la souplesse
qui aurait été nécessaire pour nous
adapter une situation nouvelle sur le
TGV moi je suis clair s'il y av pas le
TGV il y aurait plus de SNCF c'est le
TGV qui a sauvé la SNCF faut pas se
raconter
d'histoire donc moi les attaques contre
le TGV j'aime beaucoup
mais
je je crois qu'il faut être conscient de
l'enjeu qu'il y avait
derrière c'est
euh c'est une chose dont je suis fier et
dont je pense qu'il faut que les
Français soient
fiers peut-être que maintenant que le
pays est assez bien équipé il faut aller
vers comme le fait le gouvernement
actuel déplaçant de l'argent sur le
réseau
classique mais je ne voudrais pas qu'on
jette avec le béb avec Clau du bain et
que on dise que le TGV a tué le fret ou
le TER ou
l'intercité parce que sans sans le TGV
il y aurait plus de frit il y aurait
plus
d'intercité merci monsieur le Président
Madame clapau madame la députée de la
Drome vous avez la parole
oui
pardon merci merci monsieur le président
la commission d'enquête monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues euh monsieur
le Président je voudrais d'abord saluer
votre implication et les les valeurs qui
vous ont animé tout au long de votre
parcours vous êtes unanimement reconnu
comme un grand capitaine d'industrie et
je sais que vous avez fait beaucoup pour
la SNCF et en particulier pour le sujet
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui le le frais
ferroviaire que nous aimerions tous voir
prospérer alors je vais me permettre de
décentrer légèrement le regard et de
vous demander quelle est votre
vision parce
que moi je suis persuadée que le le fret
ferroviaire est bien mieux que le frite
sur les camions j'habite en vallée du rô
hein donc vous imaginez ce que ça
représente de de prendre aujourd'hui
l'autoroute avec tous ces camions qui
sont dangereux et qui
pollue il me semble que même si on aime
bien le train le train quand même des
inconvénients structurels que vous avez
rappelé les voix sont partagées alors
sauf en valler du rô mais je vais pas
revenir là-dessus o normalement il y a
une voix pour le fret une voix pour le
voyageur mais c'est pas ça qui se passe
mais en général les voix sont partagées
euh le dernier kilomètre est impossible
à desservir par le train euh on est dans
une société où les consommateurs se sont
habitués à avoir des délais très courts
donc même en B2B euh les délais se sont
beaucoup restreints
et puis il y a aussi euh une
vulnérabilité je pense hein un manque de
résilience euh du transport de du train
donc enfin à voir vous serez peut-être
pas d'accord et donc je me demande s'il
ne faut pas regarder les choses de
beaucoup plus haut et se dire que
l'innovation technologique l'innovation
sociale doit nous permettre à nous
continents européen euh d'imaginer un
transport ferroviaire de demain ou un
autre transport hein le ferroviaire ça
date de la fin du 19e siècle peut-être
que ça n'est plus adapté euh est-ce que
les autoroutes ferroviaires est-ce que
je ne sais pas moi des des voies
vraiment dédiées en
superposition est-ce que le les
innovations permises par le numérique ne
permettrait pas d'inventer un transport
ferroviaire de demain et qui permettrait
de de résorber tous ces problèmes
structurels euh qui finalement d'une
certaine façon sont sont pointés je
pense par cette action de de la
Commission
européenne merci bien
madame euh le train est assez
résilient la régularité du train
elle est
correcte on se plaint tous évidemment
des retards que l'on constate on a tous
notre petite expérience comme je disais
régulièrement le train c'est l'aventure
sans risque vous avez l'aventure parce
que de temps en temps il arrive vous
soyez en retard mais vous ne courrez pas
de risque c'est autre que de perdre du
temps
euh la résilience du la résilience du
euh du trafic marchandise est bonne
sauf sauf exception je me souviens que
nous avions perdu un train on savait pas
où il était
bon ça c'est une ça c'est une faute
faute professionnelle de SNCF de perdre
des trains ça c'est c'est c'est quelque
chose de totalement anormal
donc ça se corrige non la résilience me
paraît pas être la la cause principale
deuxièmement moi je je continue à penser
que le fret ferroviaire a du
sens que la route ne le remplacera
jamais
complètement d'abord parce que le
passage de la route de du gazol à
l'électrique ou à l'hydrogène va prendre
un temps considérable euh et s'il est
possible et deuxièmement parce que ce
mode de transport a quand même des des
avantages propres quand vous circulez
sur deux rails avec une surface de
frottement qui fait moins d'un cm ou au
de l'ORS du centimètre vous dépensez
extrêmement peu
d'énergie donc c'est un avantage que
n'aura pas la route avec les
pneus donc je je je pense que lorsqu'on
parleéconomie d'énergie on doit aussi
parler de de de
cela il faut trouver de la souplesse il
faut trouver comment on on arrive à
articuler les modes de transport ce que
vous dit comme vous le dites on fait pas
le dernier kilomètre sauf pour des des
entreprises suffisamment importantes
pour avoir des embranchements
particuliers et je pense que
euh vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
monsieur le député les emranchements
particuliers euh il est possible que
certains méritent d'être rénovés mais
encore faut-il que l'industriel en cause
le souhaite euh il faut donc le le en
discuter avec lui
euh bon voilà je
euh on disait euh dans les milieux que
je fréquenter que le valgon isolé
c'était un peu obsolète comme vous dites
est-ce qu'on n pas sur un trafic
ancien ça dépend quel trafic de
transport combiné je pense que le
passage par les triages lui est obsolè
on peut imaginer d'autres moyens de
constitution des
trains et encore une fois je je ne
voudrais pas m'élever au-dessus de ma
dignité fret et numérique je je je
j'espère que le fret c'est mis au
numérique j'en suis même
sûr
donc cela mais vous avez évoqué quelque
chose qui est très important c'est que
les consommate maintenant demande des
délais extrêmement courts le trafic
d'Amazon peut pas passer par le chemin
de
fer d'abord parce qu'il est pas il est
pas régulier et ensuite parce que la la
la rapidité n'est pas n'est pas
compatible avec le mode ferroviaire ça
c'est un
sujet il y a d'autres trafics
heureusement qui peuvent relever du du
ferroviaire dès lors qu'on est capable
d'assurer vous avez raison la régularité
trafic les horaires tenus la qualité du
transport la protection des marchandises
transportés ce qui pour les automobiles
puisque j'ai passé quelques temps dans
l'automobile est extrêmement important
parce que les voitures peuvent être
abîmées pendant les transports il faut
veiller à ce qu'elles ne soit pas mais
ell peuvent elles sont aussi abîmées par
le transport routier hein mais
l'avantage du ferroviaire c'est que
peut-être on peut dédier des
installations qui permettent de mieux
protéger les les véhicules
transportter donc donc il y a il y a des
trafics qui peuvent être le ferroviaire
à sa place et encore une fois le
transport
combiné venir de lui et puis quand on
voit la masse de containers qui arrivve
dans nos dans les
ports c'est un lieu de massification
doit pouvoir organiser les
trafic merci monsieur le Président on
est donc une question de Monsieur
Nicolas député du Cher ensuite je
redonnerai la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur que je n'ai pas oublié
évidemment
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président euh très content de ce que
vous avez pu dire sur sur le la
nécessité du frit ferroviaire et et de
sa capacité à rebondir mais aussi de de
votre de votre avis sur sur le le plan
de discontinuité qui nous semble aussi
un peu
un tout c'est un avis de quelqu'un qui
connaît la la maison et l'industrie donc
c'est intéressant et et juste une
question là-dessus vous avez vous avez
souligné que ce serait c'est juste une
question extrêmement précise pour que ce
soit bien clair vous avez dit qu'il y
avait 5 milliards d'aides qui étai qui
étaient aujourd'hui mis en cause dans la
procédure de la Commission européenne et
que ce serait un remboursement à la SNCF
de la part de fret SNCF c'est oui vous
pensez donc voilà donc vous confirmez
cette parce que c'est pas ce qui nous a
été dit ce qui à mon avis dans ce
cadrelà changerait complètement la donne
sur le le le le cadre de la
procédure je je je voudrais sur deux
points euh d'abord je j'ignore si ça
sera un remboursement de frit SNCF à
frit de de fr SNCF à
euh la discontinuité
euh je je ne confonds pas la
discontinuité et le traitement euh des
trafic ou de la dette la discontinuité
euh
elle était pratiquement je pense à
acquise par le jugement de la Commission
de
Bruxelles si la dette était remboursée
je ne sais pas qui d'autre que on
pouvait le rembourser que que qu'à la
SNCF puisque c'est la SNCF qui a fait
les fins de mois du fret bon bon mais
encore une fois je ne suis pas dans les
arcanes donc il faut que vous demandiez
à Monsieur farondou ou à d'autres euh
cela je peux me tromper je j'ai j'ai le
droit à l'erreur sur ce point puceque je
n'ai pas
d'information euh
donc je ne voudrais
pas dire des choses qui qui ne seraient
pas
conforme tout la question est de savoir
si cet accord est équilibré ou pas je le
trouve sévère
bon je le trouve sévère et surtout je
cherche en quoi il est
productif de d'une amélioration du fret
en général fr du fret fer foviaire en
général je pense qu'il ne ne règle pas
les problèmes du FR ferroviaire en
général mais encore une fois c'est un
avis qui n'engage que moi hein c'est pas
du tout citoyen
oui et d'ailleurs ici personne n'a dit
que cet accord était de nature à stimulé
le frais de ferroviaire personne pas
même le ministre le ministre l'a
présenté comme étant un accord qui lui
paraissait un moindre mal dans les
conditions qui étaient celles
aujourd'hui imposé par la concurrence et
je précise aussi pour taquiner mon
collègue du Cher que une aide publique
que vous avez perçu quel que soit la
personne à qui vous l' reversé de toute
façon vous la payz ah oui et et qu'
aurait pas de possibilité du coup du
groupe SNCF de la redonner à Fr SNCF par
quelqu voix que ce soit puisque c'est
justement cela qu' justement cela qu'on
lui reproche hein et en tout cas il
faudrait bien qu'il y ait ce versement
en intenté voilà non il est il est clair
il est clair que Bruxelles serait
extrêmement attentif à la manière dont
cette dette serait
financée et il est probable qu'il
chercherait à ce qu'elle soit financée
sur les ressources propres du fret et
pas sur d'autres ressources et notamment
pas sur des dotations capital que que
SNCF ferait à frit SNCF parce que là ça
c'est c'est la boucle qui boucle c'est
très commode mais je ne me paraît pas ça
ne me paraît pas je connais suffisamment
pas très bien mais enfin je connais
suffisamment les autorités bruxelloises
pour savoir qu'elle ne se ferait pas
avoir par une entourloupe comme celle-là
et et et quant au jugement du ministre
moi je n'ai pas d'élément qui me
permettent de dire qu'il a tort quand il
dit c'est un moindre mal mais c'est un
mal parce que le je je dis cela parce
que je
je ce qui me semble qu'on touche du
doigt depuis plusieurs auditions c'est
ce sujet de la manière dont le droit de
la concurrence est aujourd'hui pensé et
dont il vient heurter un impératif de
politique publique qui n'était pas aussi
présent au moment où vous avez exercé la
présidence de la SNCF qui est celui de
la décarbonation des transports et ce
lien entre Fret SNCF et la transition
écologique qui devient Fret SNCF je
dirais plutôt le développement du fret
au sens large du fret de ferroviaire qui
devient un lien automatique et donc on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a un
impératif de politique publique sur la
transition écologique et la
décarbonation des mobilités qui est
aussi poursuivi par Bruxelles
avec des aides à l'investissement sur le
réseau ferroviaire les infrastructures
dédiées ou le passage au gabarit P4 son
qui sont pas toujours d'ailleurs
complètement intégrés dans la stratégie
SNCF et de l'autre côté on a des
directives sur la concurrence qui
peuvent apparaître en partie heurter
celle-ci voilà c'est plus comme ça qu'il
faut je je pense pas je pense pas trahir
complètement votre pensée en disant cela
monsieur le rapporteur allez-y je je
voudrais dire quand même un mot si vous
me permettez euh
la Commission européenne est extrêmement
vigilante sur la sur la la la
concurrence entre les entreprises
ferroviaires je n'ai pas entendu qu'elle
s'intéressait à la concurrence
intermodale je pense qu'elle pourrait
regarder la concurrence intermodale pour
savoir si elle est
équilibrée moi je pense que c'est un
sujet tout à fait dans le cadre de ses
attributions de protéger la concurrence
pure et
parfaite donc je l'encourage j'encourage
la Commission à s'intéresser à la
concurrence intermodale qui est
infiniment supérieure infiniment plus
dure pour les transporteurs ferroviaires
que la concurrence
intramodale merci merci monsieur le
Président
dans dans un des dans un des avis qui
qui n'engage que vous
monsieur vous avez indiqué
euh je cite la situation du frêtre va
être difficile dans les prochaines
années
euh portant ce ce jugement
euh pourriez-vous
l'étayer euh et plus particulièrement
nous dire est-ce que vous jugez que
cette situation va être difficile dans
les prochaines
années au
vu du paysage nouveau qui va être celui
de la filière
euh des différents opérateurs y compris
avec l'entité nouvelle dont on nous dit
donc qu'elle sera sur le segment
euh du fr mutualisé et peut-être un avis
de votre part sur l'avenir de ce segment
ou tout autant ou différemment par
rapport à aux objectifs de rénovation
des réseau d'une part et de
réindustrialisation vous êtes sur ce
point quand même
aviser qui sont devant nous
sachant que lorsque vous indiquer la
situation du fred va être difficile dans
les prochaines années euh portez-vous un
jugement à échéance 2030 et donc
à l'étiage d'un engagement majeur qui
est celui du doublement du trafic frit
dans notre pays pour le passer à à 18
%. je dis que quand on enlève près de 15
% du trafic à une
entreprise et que on lui enlève une part
rentable je sais pas si c'est la plus
rentable j'ai pas j'ai pas d'objection
je pas mais on lui enlève des trafics
rentables on on on l'amène dans une
situation
difficile je n'ai pas d'autres élément
d'appréciation voilà donc c'est à c'est
à la SNCF de vous dire qu'elle F de ses
difficultés et comment elle envisage de
les
surmonter mais je imagine pas je j'ai
j'ai dirigé un certain nombre
d'entreprises si on me disait du jour au
Lain vous enlève 15 % de votre trafic et
puis vous allez passer à vos concurrents
un certain nombre de contrats qui sont
parmi ceux qui vous rapportai de
l'argent
euh j'aurais trouvé que c'était une on
créé une situation difficile c'est cela
que je dis et que je ne je ne voudrait
pas que ça entraîne un effet boule de
neige c'est-à-dire que euh
en rendant la situation plus difficile
on on retrouve les problèmes qu'on avait
avant que le frê été remis à l'équilibre
parce que d'après ce que je lis dans le
journal depuis 2 ans le fr éta à
l'équilibre donc on est en train de
remettre en cause une situation où le fr
à l'équilibre est-ce qu'il pourra
continuer à l'être dans les dans les
après ce choc je l'espère et je suis sûr
que la SNCF y travaille mais euh je dis
que ça va être un travail euh
ardu monsieur le Président après votre
présidence donc du Group public
ferroviaire vous avez pris la tête de
ADS et donc d'erbus euh pendant 6 ans et
puis vous avez été président du conseil
de surveillance jusqu'à il y a 2 ans de
du groupe
PSA euh je vois que rien ne vous échappe
ou c'est sont pas des informations aussi
secrètes que certaines desquelles on on
peut avoir accès dans une commission
d'enquête
euh merci de votre votre ironie euh
c'est toujours une forme d'élégance et
et une forme de salut à à l'intelligence
de celui auquel on s'adresse et monsieur
le Président vous avez donc œuvré au
premier plan dans ce secteur
aéronautique puis dans le secteur de
l'automobile qui sont des secteurs qui
peuvent pour certaines activités
recourir au frais de ferroviaire est-ce
que sur ces période là qui s'étendent
finalement entre 2006 et et 2021 vous
avez identifié une forme de perte
d'attractivité du fra de ferroviaire
pour transporter des véhicules ou des
éléments de construction aéronautique et
si oui à quoi cela était-il dû selon
vous du côté d'erbus il y avait très peu
de trafic par le chemin de fer
honnêtement ça se prête très mal ce sont
des petites quantités on fabrique pas
des millions d'avions chaque année sont
des petites quantités ce sont des
trafics extrêmement encombrants on met
ça sur des P niche sur des bateaux même
pour les ailes de les ailes de la 380
pour les ailes de
350 on essaie d'enfiler ça dans le
beloua qui est un avion qui transporte
les
charges la la la le le frais de
ferroviaire n'est manifestement pas
complètement adapté à cela pour
l'automobile en revanche c'est un très
gros trafic c'est un trafic historique
de CF la perte d'activité
d'attractivité
oui je
senti je pense alors est-ce que c'est un
parce que des mesures ont été prise ou
parce que les constructeurs automobiles
se sont rabattus sur une solution qu'il
jugeait plus pratique il y a les deux il
y a les deux et je je je pense que les
trafics automobiles ont baissé
depuis depuis 2006 je nai pas le chiffre
je n'ai pas les chiffres mais si je
regarde le groupe PSA je sais que ça a
baissé très
sérieusement il se trouve que j'étais à
Bordeaux 7 semaine et j'ai vu passer
dans la Gard de Bordeaux un train de
voiture Volkswagen qui remonta d'Espagne
ça m'a donné
quelques quelques espoirs
oui oui c'est c'est c'est clair que il
faut r il faut que le le fret
réapparaisse comme une
solution il a reconstruire ça
d'apparaître comme une solution qui que
l'on préfère à une autre et les
arguments écologiques ne sont pas nul
parce que tout le monde va avoir à
rendre compte des efforts qu'il fait y
compris chez ses fournisseurs et la SNCF
est le fournisseur de du du constructeur
donc cet argument
devra pe peut être un des éléments mais
il faut il faut comme vous le disiez
madame la résilience aussi la la qualité
des
trafic peut-être le
prix mais euh pour les constructeurs
automobile le trafic ferroviaire est un
trafic quand même assez commode parce
que il il permet de de Al là il y a
d'abord les emanchements particulier
existe avec les usines et d'autre part
euh on peut charger beaucoup de voitures
sur un
train je je partage simplement avec la
commission euh
certaines des réflexions aussi qu'on
entend et je sais que certains les ont
entendu auprès de des chargeurs ou des
logisticiens il y a aussi une réalité de
la culture logistique qui au cours des
20 dernières années en France a fait que
le Fred s'est trouvé progressivement
marginalisé parce que le coût d'entrée
humain dans l'activité frit est très
élevée ça demande on en parlait tout à
l'heure en marge de cette commission
d'enquête avec un de nos
collègues en terme de formation en terme
d'appréhension tout simplement de de la
logique du fris de ferroviaire qui est
toujours plus compliqué que la logique
routière toujours et donc tout
simplement dans les dans beaucoup je
suis sûr que si on prenait les maquettes
pédagogiques de beaucoup d'écoles qui
formaient des logisticiens on trouverait
que la part réservée aux autres modes y
compris au fluvial était relativement
mince en France au cours des 20
dernières années c'est serait et que
c'est c'était devenu une solution assez
assez marginal assez compliqué peut-être
aussi que le gros public ferroviaire
mais là c'est des des des chose qu'on
partage ici que fredf n'avait pas su
faire partager cette culture et que
parfois elle avait l'impression que
c'était quelque chose qui lui était
propre et elle ne partageit pas assez
elle essayait pas de faire rentrer les
logisticiens dans ses logiques propres
et que c'est l'une des difficultés à
laquelle en revanche par exemple VO
navigable de France a sur Répondre
depuis pas mal d'années maintenant de
façon un peu plus dynamique voilà c'est
c'est des hypothèses que je pose ici
devant vous j'ai pas d'avis sur VO
navigable de France
mais ce que vous dites est vrai c'est
c'est-à-dire que dans le scope des
solutions le frais de ferroviaire
n'apparaît plus toujours
et donc il faut le
remettre il faut le remettre mais pour
cela il faut certainement une politique
de communication il faut une politique
de contact client et il y a aussi il
faut arriver avec des
éléments
précis
infrastructure
trafic
continuité du trafic et résilience du
trafic et
cetera très bien merci monsieur le
Président je crois qu'il n'y a plus de
question on va pouvoir vous libérer
merci beaucoup du temps que vous avez
passé avec notre commission d'enquête
donc on peut marquer une petite pause
avant d'auditionner monsieur